week now unfortunately tonight
the hate rage in anti-trump psychosis
being directed towards republicans
is hitting new lows for example just
look
at this reprehensible cartoon published
in the washington post of all places
depicting republican lawmakers is actual
rats
and accusing them of quote subverting
the constitution
end quote and it gets worse because far
left
actor george takai tweeted this attack
on senator rubio
quote there are very very few instances
of known allergic reactions to the covet
19 vaccine
but marco rubio has always thought of
himself as
one in a million so there's still hope
and that's not all because
unhinged actor alec baldwin is fueling
even more violent rhetoric towards the
president and his supporters
tweeting who arrests trump if he refuses
to concede
who drags him out before adding a knee
on his neck
cutting off his oxygen does he wheeze i
can't breathe
and of course congressional democrats
still can't help but push
more russia hysteria and collusion
delusion
like california's maxine waters who's
now claiming that congress
missed an opportunity to impeach
president trump for
treason over ties to russia i wow
so much for well you know when they go
low we go
high that that never came to fruition
but of course this is what we've come to
expect from the new extreme
raged field left spewing endless hate
and personal attacks
against those who dare to call out their
rampant hypocrisy
and outright lies in misinformation
we'll join